[Music]
in mosque have it news give it to me
luck nevermind like Elon Musk Elon Musk
submitted by you know who I am nope do
Oh Charles Oh Charlie the chaplain
Charleston
oh yeah Charleston I'm or tan tan oh
yeah Elon Musk recently sold nine
million dollars worth of flamethrowers I
go it's for Rihanna buy one yeah it's
for real
he sold them I need Lou's making them
he started out you know they're they're
legal here in California flamethrowers a
lot people were going buzzer guys that
picture again that looks tight it's
called the boring company 500 that's one
from her boss yes he created this
company is called the boring company he
created it last year when he was stuck
in traffic and he was like you know what
we should have underground tunnels to
clear up traffic and so that's when he
started creating this company
flamethrowers oh we could clear up
traffic with the flamethrowers no so
initially he was selling had 20 bucks
each and he said that if he sells a
certain amount of hats and he'll be
selling flamethrowers next and so he
stuck to his promise that is honestly
though what is that that what what is he
selling after the flamethrowers can I
still buy one is the question no it's
now so why did he have to be so high
peace about it and do limited quantities
because they only wanted to sell they're
not Jordans just keep cleaning them out
he's basically just gonna sell grand
theft auto weapons is what I mean
oh yeah hell yeah so rocket launches
next you know that's funny too cuz they
also were selling a fire extinguisher
with it I don't know if I don't give a
[ __ ] about that but the fire
extinguisher it says the description it
says buy an overpriced boring company
fire extinguisher you can definitely buy
one for Less elsewhere but this one
comes with a cool sticker and the button
is conveniently right above you have a
picture of the fire extinguisher that
should like that though when the
company's witty like that it just makes
me want to buy into it I'm just stupid I
wish it had the backpack though like the
ones that you
yeah they had the back all flamethrower
yeah I thought fire extinguisher might
that's pretty cool too for you could
have your buddy who has like the
extinguisher and you have the
flamethrower and then you know you could
play a game where like who could burn it
or extinguish it Oh fires one of those
things I'm scared to play with because
that [ __ ] like once it catches it like
it's like wildfire
it just spreads really [ __ ] fast I
love fire I love playing with fire what
fire is like so awesome how would you
play with it how would you play with a
stubborn napkins us run around
burn napkins and just run around yeah
that's actually frightening it when you
run to like a trash can
that's what's so bad have you ever
burned uh spaghetti like hard uncut
spaghetti
oh really cool it's kind of like an
infant thing oh that's so gross remember
I like I like different kind of sprays
like with the match I mean the the
lighter yeah yeah it's great like what
the hairspray always did well raid it up
[ __ ] pretty crazy
great yeah ray you did you relate farts
up no I Chinese your people will touch
stuff no cuz I honestly never did I
couldn't get it to work oh you tried
though yeah well we all did it everyone
in my home have you seen those videos of
guys doing that and if they burn their
ass No yeah I give the hair catches on
that yeah could the winds go in their
direction no just like it's like that
did you ever stick a firecracker in your
butt and then like that of course you
did no what the hell kind of question is
that yeah
sparklers okay you can watch jackass
they did it no of course I didn't do
what Jackass they just laughed at it
instead of what a bunch of [ __ ] he is
so what Jackass guys don't know is that
when minorities watch jackass I think
all white people do that yeah yeah is
that right there's a representation of
all white people American us wait yeah
so you got to talk to your fellow
brothers I guess so cuz you you did
validate my thought of like oh all us
white people like their farts on fire
nude you did confirm that I mean yeah in
middle school I think everyone did
though
I remember minorities in mine in mine
class we're doing it as well maybe it's
a guy thing I think it's a guy it
crossed my mind yeah it did but and I
just I didn't have a fart prepared for
it the only time I was ever successful
it was in Boy Scouts who already had a
campfire going and then I went up to it
and then I fired it you you put it up to
a [ __ ] the campfire and it worked
yeah how close did you have a bar you oh
you have to get you have to get pretty
close and I think it's also like the
methane content in your farts so it's
gotta be on those stinky ones yeah we
should try it again that's why I work
out yeah but as soon as it comes out of
there it's not gonna be anything that's
what's cool look okay the thing yeah
have you guys ever had those like snake
things it's like a copper little pill
thing I'm not copper it's like it's like
aluminum looking and then you light it
and it just it grows yeah what the hell
was that when I was growing up we used
to go to buy those at the fireworks
stand
Oh know what they I always thought was
weird as why are all fireworks stands
made out of wood cause if it's gonna
catch on fire like you have like
accident everyone the whole team is
burning down wood it looks like
two-by-fours to me it does look yeah I
just looks like regular wood it just
looks like if you want to cause some
trouble you just close the door lock it
and throw some [ __ ] lighter fluid in
there and everyone there's a sausage I
guess to the firework guys or like if we
make this sentimental what's the [ __ ]
difference like if it all goes up it all
goes up yeah how much were the flame
Thor's 500 that's cheap I wish I signed
up there like a lot must move later
like how legal is it can I use it in my
backyard talking about the legal stuff
there there's only two states in the
whole United States that have
restrictions against owning a fire
flamethrower
only two of those were one I'm also born
California and Maryland they're saying
that it's completely banned in Maryland
but in California if you obtain a permit
issue by the State Fire Marshal then
it's okay so wait so it's like hey for
Fire Marshal like me and my buddies we
just want to light up like a bunch of
toilet like a whole big pyramid of
toilet paper and he's like that sounds
very legitimate we're gonna grant you
like what is the criteria why would we
need a fire throw a Mustang
I mean sure I'll preorder this philsie
legal though and then he says ATF says
any flame thrower with a flame shorter
than 10 feet is a-okay our design is max
fun for at least danger I'd be way more
scared of a steak knife so this is
that's true I'm pretty scared steak
knives this is one with to terrify me
with the flamethrower
oh he burned some [ __ ] let's watch it
he's so fun it's like a super soaker
bullet fire that is so strange being you
on Elon Musk you're a billionaire and
you do that to your friend and your
friends like I'm suing you for millions
of dollars why wouldn't you course our
money people get [ __ ] cheesy that is
[ __ ] that's you every one of you I
mean I sue back should be like a big C
game it's kind of like I bet you you
just start suing each other
dude the lawyers would love working for
us once we get rich as [ __ ] I can't wait
to see you right now right I'll just see
you back for the same amount we just
keep passing money back and forth we'll
go get lunch oh yeah so optimistic yeah
this [ __ ] fool that's tight so it's
like a it's like a it's not even like a
flame thrower to me you know what it
looks like those butane lighters
yeah yeah I would like to see him make
one in the shape of a sword they look
like a lightsaber a fire similar like it
catches on fire and then you can just
think what you cannot like a sword you
do oh yeah I see that
wow that you showed it to me are we side
here I don't know how do you men not
know this lightsabers fire sword yeah
can you imagine an axe but on both sides
it like Shh
like turns out like a propane line
that'd be so sick yeah that's gonna cool
oh my god everything fire why is it
though why don't we all love the [ __ ]
with fire in it like every I know I
remember every video game that I played
growing up like as you got better in the
game the your weapon got more flames on
it why do we like that's it I bet it's
like one of those biological like we
evolved it fire - like rely on it or
something cuz it makes me go like yes
fire yeah cuz you know how devastating
that [ __ ] is like you can't escape fire
like once you're in it you're [ __ ] you
know what I actually I think I could
have skipped fire I really do
I don't know what can we can't we know
what you know what it is is cuz I and
this is so biased of me but every time I
read like all of this person like they
got trapped in a fire I'm always like
you couldn't get out away from a fire
it's hard but of course it's hard right
but but I don't you don't think of it
like that what are your thoughts
well I'm biased because my own
experiences of fire are very controlled
yeah so that's why I don't that's why I
think I could outrun a fire you've never
been in a fire field building I was in a
burning garage we had to fight the fire
and the fire was were like where Bart
was that and I was like oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] strong like a [ __ ] and
they were like trying to blast it with
watch thousands of degrees where there's
a real fire - means like people get
killed by snakes right like it's like
how did you like you couldn't run away
from snakes snakes are fast how fast
could they be do you like I go now I've
moved nine miles an hour or they could
just bite your ankle when you're in a
clicking so nothing the faster than you
think I gotta earn a snake dude no
problem snakes are fast though
see those Cobras [ __ ] chasing after a
little Mongoose or like the planet Earth
seen when they're the snakes are trying
to get the lizard they're fat they're
definitely fast but I got way longer
legs in the lizard okay I'm like 6 foot
freakin and a half like when you get
bitten by a snake it's always you never
saw it coming yeah it's an ankle biter
well I'm thinking about if it snake is
chasing you and then you get bit then
you're a loser
see I think you're then you deserve to
kind of dive snake go like that's right
Oh what and then after that if it has to
run as - dude this thing there's not a
run in a straight line supposed to turn
around and run when you see a snake
you're supposed to [ __ ] go right is
that ready beagles are bears I don't
know makes you scared of you too like if
you're bigger than them looking you
don't do that to a rooster though
roosters will [ __ ] you up you think you
can [ __ ] a party no how a snake feels
pal I don't trust them this makes up
something you want to eat I agree with
you I don't like having food chain in my
house right looks like I have cats and
if a snake could eat my cat why would I
order to do that you know I mean like if
I leave you if your snake in the
aquarium one day some shits gonna go
down they don't care about you yeah it's
like having mice and having like like
cats like why would you have a pair and
a dog and like and where they just eat
each other I'll probably over one pet
left yeah just one bad day yeah
hey better than the me
[Music]